oder die ganze haut ist rot sie haben
als bistro überall
guck mal hier rein überall
hey leute was klappt jetzt willkommen
beim ein video aber natürlich hoffe euch
geht's gut wie heute wir haben heute
montag und ich habe gestern abend nach
sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr weil ich auch auf jeden
fall habe ich noch sehr sehr lange zeit
mal wieder fernsehen geguckt und
irgendwie ging es bei seiner sendung
umso selbstbräuner die meisten von euch
denken jetzt wahrscheinlich oh nein alex
probieren bloß keinen selbstbräuner die
haben erst zu sein
natürlich kannte ich selbstbräuner
vorher schon nur ich habe irgendwie
immer so gedacht hey das ist der grösste
rotz und das wird auf keinen fall
funktionieren oder ist sie total
künstlich aus nur um ehrlich zu sein
gestern in der sendung sah es eigentlich
gar nicht so schlecht aus so leute hier
in sich zieht man es jetzt vielleicht
nicht ganz so krass aber wir haben ja
schon oktober und ich bin relativ blass
treffer ungefähr einen monat oder 100
monate noch im urlaub aber ja meine haut
ist blass und wasser sind
experimentierfreudiger youtuber bin habe
ich mir gedacht komm du hast ja nichts
zu verlieren probier's doch einfach mal
ausgleicht ist du mal aufzutragen der
woche lang oder so wie sich das
entwickelt natürlich wenn ich jetzt auch
sehr wie solle frittierte pommes dann
mach ich das wieder weg aber man kann
selber versuchen ich habe für das ganze
aber noch einen test kaninchen
organisiert juli hey willst du auch
mitmachen
heute also ich bin sehr gespannt was
passieren wird und vielleicht sicher am
ende der woche echt gut aus weil um
ehrlich zu sein so sachen wie solar und
das finde ich echt so ein bisschen
schädlich also ich glaube ich könnte
mich nicht unter so ein solarium legen
weil ich weiß das ist nicht gut für die
haut ich glaube da ist diese
selbstbräuner krems von die bessere
alternative
wir gehen das gleich mal muss schauen
dass sie um die ecke postbank gibt oder
es wird dann gekauft letzten jahr 2013
drin mexiko könnte mal bitte allen
daumen nach oben geben für unser neues
open schild hier mega cool oder
so leute wir haben
das gerade schon abend es sind einige
stunden vergangen wir haben einfach
stand gleich jetzt auf jeden fall war
ich heute erst ein bisschen lernen und
dann habe ich noch fußball geguckt ja
und es sei aber ganz wichtig natürlich
ich war einkaufen die verkäuferin hat
mich etwas blöd angeguckt weil ich habe
drei verschiedene forschungs cremen
mitgenommen hat halt recht überhaupt
keine ahnung davon
wir haben ja einmal wahrscheinlich habe
jetzt voll das wahrscheinlich habe ich
jetzt komplett falsch gekauft und zwar
einmal passiert das hat ein eur 990
gekostet das war das günstigste selbst
bräunungsmittel helle haut ja meine haut
deshalb hält dann haben wir hier was für
fünf euro
feuchtigkeit wenn du selbst räumungs
mich so gespannt ob das klappt
das hier von l'oreal hat zehn euro
kostet 10 euro das mal anders kann ich
10 euro kosten
okay du bist eine zehn euro wird auf
jeden fall ich würd sagen wir fangen
erst mal mit dem gesicht an
und dafür müssen wir logischerweise ins
warten ich hatte dieses schild also so
oder so ist auch diesen pulli habe ich
übrigens zugeschickt bekommen von dem
moment dann für die ganzen sachen habe
mich sehr gefreut und jetzt ist sommer
obwohl heute baut werden das steht uns
drauf die bräunung ist nach zwei drei
stunden abgeschlossen ich nicht dass ich
es verschlafen und mein ganzes bett dann
wollen braun nützlich weil das ding ist
ich habe auch ein bisschen angst davor
ich höre ich froh dass ich richtig blöd
aus und es geht einfach nicht mehr weg
und ich gehe natürlich kann ihn nicht so
ausgeht und das ganze macht nochmal auf
die
das sieht ja gar nicht was das ist ja
was ist das richtige
und es ist ein bisschen wie jugend punkt
komma strich fertig ist das hübsche
gesicht der welt ach so und für alle die
jetzt in die kommentare schreiben
ist der schwul nein bin ich nicht ich
finde es aber auch so so absolut gar
keine sind schneiden wenn man meint man
möchte ein bisschen feuerwehren dann
können auch jungs auch scream benutzen
und hat sich schon was verändert
wahrscheinlich nicht wie vielleicht geht
das hier auf den haben also das ganze
jetzt gerade so aus ich weiß jetzt echt
nicht ob da irgendwie schauen ob das ein
bisschen an sich ist es nicht getan
ich bin auf jeden fall gespannt ich
denke in zwei richtungen merkt schon
schlafen aber mal sehen ob wir morgen
jedoch ein ergebnis sie weil das hilft
besonders überhaupt halten egal ich bin
manchmal aufbauen
ich wünsche euch eine gute nach wir
sehen uns leute was geht
ich muss mal kurz ein kleines update
geben ich habe das nicht gemerkt deine
haut krieg richtig an zu jucken und
meine haut ich hoffe man sieht es gut
meine haut ist unfassbar roth an einigen
stellen
und ich weiß dass gerade ich so recht
was ich machen sollte als es brennt
jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr nur seeed
ein bisschen komisch aber ich habe es
jetzt gleich was ganz so gut es geht
wieder runter oder wasser waschen konnte
weil es echten kracher ausschlagen oder
die ganze haut ist rot haben hals bis
zum überall
guck mal hier rein das überall
hey was falls hautirritationen auftreten
anwendung einstellen
beim aufenthalt in der sonne unbedingt
ihr eigenes sonnenschutz also leute hier
muss man sagen der preis macht es
anscheinend weil ich bin eigentlich
gegen nichts ändere mich also wirklich
nicht trage jetzt gar nicht heute nichts
mehr auf wir sehen uns schon morgen
wieder contest noch mal das andere aber
das war ein schuss in den ofen team kind
sowie bastel darf herzlich willkommen
zumal jetzt muss ich mal kurz zusammen
auf jeden fall habe ich ja gestern einen
ziemlichen ausschlag bekommen also es
war echt krass ich war wirklich
zwischendurch komplett im ganzen gesicht
rot also das was sich da gestern benutzt
haben war echt nicht gut also für mich
auf keinen fall für das jetzt nicht
verallgemeinern vielleicht war ich jetzt
einzelfall kein plan ja da noch machen
wir natürlich weiter und zwar dann haben
wir hier den garnier ambre solaire
natural bäume bronx natural power
spendet der haut lang anhaltende
feuchtigkeit und verleiht ihren kurzer
zeit eine schöne gleichmäßige natürliche
bräune und ich würde sagen wir machen
was ein grund ist hier so und gucken was
heute daraus wird also das könnte ich
echt schon besser als gestern so ich
will sagen ich lasse das ganze jetzt mal
einziehen ich melde mich dann in zwei
stunden wieder und dann bin ich mal
gespannt wie es aussieht ich habe jetzt
auf jeden fall mal abgewartet und wie
man sieht sieht man eigentlich nicht
viel
also ich weiß nicht vielleicht schon
leichte unterschied sehen ich bin noch
nicht so ganz überzeugt deswegen tragen
wir es ist einfach noch mal auf und
einfach sich auch in die stadt weil wir
noch fußball gucken heute da muss ich ja
erst mal wer da was tun obwohl
vielleicht ich bin bisher unsicherheit
schon eigentlich oder findest du ich bin
beinahe geworden jetzt soll ich denn da
was geht ab leute schönen guten morgen
ich weiß nicht ob wir es sofort sieht
aber wenn man mal darauf achtet ich bin
echt braun oder orange oder irgendeine
menschen davon konnte ich meine es ist
mir irgendwie gestern abend aufgefallen
und ich dachte hey was damit passiert so
sagen welche im krankenhaus gewesen ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen wenn es dunkel
ist dann ist es okay aber jetzt sehe ich
aus wie sonova sobald ich bin jetzt
gerade auf dem rückweg von der uni guckt
euch mal meine handflächen ich weiß man
dass hier auf erkennt aber ich habe
einen neuen spitznamen und zwar habe ich
heute in der uni ein geschenk bekommt
ist eine karotte
ich meine so nah wie heute war es wieder
ja wir haben jetzt schon was haben wir
heute heute ist donnerstag ich habe
damit angefangen also auf jeden fall
haben wir jetzt schon donnerstagabend
ich habe ja erst angefangen mit diesem
zeug für zwei euro dann jetzt vorgestern
gegen vergessen hatte genau gestern habe
ich das andere zweck probiert was mich
jetzt ich habe das ganze erst einmal so
nachmittags angemeldet gegen 15 uhr
glaube ich da ist mir so an sich nicht
wirklich viel aufgefallen und ja ich
habe das heute morgen erst oder als ich
halte der uni war gemerkt das ist voll
krass angeschlagen irgendwie ihr habt ja
auch schon gesehen ich weiß nicht in
meinem gesicht ob man das noch so
grassiert ich wollte das schon weg war
schon weil es war echt krass man guckt
man hier stehen darüber gesagt und das
ist das erste das war das zweite und das
ist das was jetzt zehn euro gekostet hat
schaut euch mal meine haut an also man
sieht es auf jeden fall richtig krass
ich wollte heute den ganzen tag über
nicht alles genannt sondern konnte das
krasseste sind aber einfach meine
handfläche passt nur auf leute was ist
das das ist einfach orange gehabt
irgendwie vergessen dass abzuwischen das
muss ich jetzt besser machen dann sag
ihr auch heute mal so lang ich weiß
nicht wann kannst du dich aber gleich
zehn es geht hier so lange am lustigsten
ist eigentlich immer ich bin sonntag in
münchen auch der pakete premiere
und wenn ich pech habe und dass jetzt
kassiert dann sich entweder zu nicht gut
aus oder absolut scheiße
ihr werdet sehen also dieses zeug kann
man ja absolut komplett in mülheim
das hier war wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
zu braun für mich und jetzt vielleicht
der wirkung dieses videos ich bin
gespannt wie ich aussehe
ich würde sagen jetzt gehen wir mal
richtig aufs ganze ich musste
fit machen für den sommer deswegen ich
über streiks ist auch nicht also ich
nicht so viel essen möchte ich es auch
geben meinen augen bin irgendwie habe
ich gestern doch im bild vergessen und
was ich an dieser stelle sagen muss ich
finde dass es auf jeden fall eines
meiner videos durch auf jeden fall den
fettesten daumen nach oben verlegt hat
weil wir geben sich schon freiwillig im
winter jeden tag so an wie ich nun für
euch testen welche bräunungscreme denn
am besten ist die frage ist so ist es
gerade überhaupt noch uci oder auf
welcher plattform befinden wir uns also
sollte ich geh jetzt werden wir jetzt so
wird die handflächen musste ich noch
abspülen und dann sehen wir uns mal
wieder ein bisschen junge leute was geht
das ist eigentlich so schade ist es
schon wieder dunkel ich weiß nicht ob
man zu krass alter kommt mal wieder
anders aus
auf jeden fall wahrscheinlich hat den
ganzen tag nicht zu hause und habe
deswegen war so wenig zeit irgendwie
dieses video ein bisschen weiter
voranzuschreiten aber ich hoffe wirklich
so dass man das sehen kann im verlauf
des videos wie diese selbst freuen dann
wirklich aussehen weil gerade der zum
beispiel der ist echt mega gut verteilt
und ich sehe einfach gut gebräunt
ausstößt sagen ich trage das heute abend
noch einmal auf und dann wenn ich mal
gespannt wie das ganze morgen aussieht
ob es gut aussieht ob es schlecht
aussieht und dann ist ja ein schon
wieder fasste warum also ist weder so
hatte einen wunderschönen guten morgen
gestern leider nicht geschafft doch mal
zu filmen aber ich weiß nicht ihr könnt
ja mal sagen wie es aussieht also leute
was sagt ihr
also ich finde ich sehr auf jeden fall
richtig gut gebräunt aber es gab schon
so künstlich um ehrlich zu sein
so leute ich habe jetzt mein koffer
gepackt und für mich geht es jetzt nach
hamburg weil heute spielt hamburg in
bayern und starten das angucken ich
völlig vergessen aber wir machen das
jetzt auf den weg und ich freue mich
hast du was macht sagen was ich bin
jetzt vielleicht wahrscheinlich noch mit
iphone
vielleicht sieht man das ganze dann auch
mal ein bisschen besser das ding ist
halt die sony ist extrem genau und man
sieht wirklich genau alles ich weiß
nicht ob man das so gut erkennt im
gesamtbild an so wie es halt wirklich
aussieht werden sehen und ja bis gleich
wir gucken uns ist ein bisschen das
spiel dahin geschafft
das war knapp was hast du dann zu meiner
freundin da ich habe ich gedacht da
irgendwo aus dem urlaub kommen
eigentlich haben wir gar keine karte
so weggefressen das wort dass das war
eine rote karte
so leute wie ba hat bei dem
hamburg-spiel gesponnen hat pflanzt mich
auf jeden fall dank für die einladung
habe mich super gefreut wie sehr sie
einen hätte das ende der firma top
organisation und dann kann diese stelle
auch noch mal wieder kräfte so leute ja
wir haben jetzt heute sonntag ich muss
mich auch ziemlich beeilen ich wollte
dass wieder eigentlich empfehlen
raushauen
aber ich will jetzt gerade schon in
münchen ja also so sehe ich gerade aus
ziemlich braun und ich finde der letzte
hat auf jeden fall richtig rein gewalt
also als abschließendes resümee würde
ich sagen wenn man ein bisschen bräuner
werden möchte dann geht nicht auf eine
sonnenbank sondern holt euch den den
alex für zehn euro gekauft hat und ich
mich zwei mal drauf und dann hat man
eine schöne bräune kümmere ich sie
richtig gesund aus ja ansonsten hab ich
irgendwie glocke oder das video hat euch
gefallen
das ist auf jeden fall noch unklar ich
hätte auch die fackelte premiere ich
freue mich richtig und ich wünsche euch
noch einen schönen sonntag
haut rein wir sehen uns 6 nations tag
überhaupt ganz wichtig